hey everyone and welcome to f8 so if you
look back at Facebook five years ago
most of the content that people shared
was text now today it's photos another
visual content if you fast-forward five
years it's going to be video and if you
look out even further beyond that it's
probably gonna be even more immersive
content like VR and air I want to show
you something kind of fun it's it's a
bit futuristic but it's an example of
the kind of content that we expect to
see in the system over time these are
our spherical videos you can move around
within it and you can change your
viewing angle now this is a new and much
more immersive type of content it's not
something that you just consume
passively you're actually interacting
with it and you feel like you're there
so soon we're going to start supporting
spherical videos a news feed today we're
introducing messenger platform so we're
going to talk about two things and the
first is giving people more tools for
expression I'm going to show you quickly
how this works so we're expanding the
composer and messenger so now you're
going to be able to easily inline find
different services that help you say
anything you want better you can create
content you can share it directly into
messenger here's an example of just a
really quick video that we made right
before this with an app called JibJab I
I said this to our our developer team
who's working on Facebook platform
congratulating them on shipping this and
yeah it's simple it's fun it's easy now
the second thing that we want to talk
about is making messenger a place where
you can easily communicate with the
businesses you care about so for example
right after you purchase something
online if you need to change your order
you're gonna be able to do that right
and messenger you're gonna receive a
receipt as well as shipping information
you can track your package and for the
rest of this talk today we're gonna
focus on all of the ways that you can
use the Facebook family to build grow
and monetize your apps
today we're launching completely new
versions of our comments plugin and our
embed video plugin so when someone sent
me this article on HuffPo telling me
about how to raise a kind daughter I
wanted to comments on it the new version
of the comments plug-in when I comments
on an article on Huffington Post the
same comment will now appear on the
Facebook page as well and that means
when my sister Caroline replies will see
a conversation together in the same
place its next let's talk about video so
today we're introducing the Facebook
embedded video player which makes it
really easy to take any video that's
publicly shared on Facebook and put it
on your site this greatly increases the
number of videos that you can pull from
and if you're posting video content on
Facebook this dramatically increases the
potential reach of your content in the
next decade we're gonna be able to build
some amazing things together
let's go connect the world
[Music]